hello my name is andres modano sosa and
i am a high school student from mexico
city
i'm currently an omixologic
bioinformatics research fellow and i am
truly passionate about biochemistry
systems biology and neuroscience
i am particularly interested in the
biological mechanisms that underlie
aging and neurodegenerative diseases
over the last three months i've been
working on my research project together
with my mentor dr hybrid koi
my research project seeks to evaluate
the role of microglial cells in the
pathogenesis and progression of
alzheimer's disease
alzheimer's disease is a progressive and
irreversible neurodegenerative disorder
that results in the development of
cognitive deficits and clinical dementia
alzheimer's disease is characterized by
the development of two pathological
hallmarks
xenoplakes which arise you to the
aggregation of the amyloid beta peptide
and neurofibrillary tangles which arise
due to the hyperphosphorylation of the
tau protein
although these two hallmarks are widely
recognized as the two core pathologies
of alzheimer's disease
the mechanisms by which they are linked
remain uh largely unknown
over the last decade the role of near
inflammation and in the pathogenesis and
progression of alzheimer's disease
has become more and more evident
patients that suffer from alzheimer's
disease show an elevated level of
inflammation in their brains
this inflammatory response in the brain
is mediated by microglial cells
the brain's resident macrophages
scientists have shown that
immunoactivation of microglial cells
leads to the secretion of
pro-inflammatory cytokines
and this inflammatory response has been
shown to exacerbate
both amyloid and tau pathologies
therefore many scientists have begun to
appreciate um
near inflammation as the third core
pathology of alzheimer's disease
as it may provide a link between the
accumulation of cynical flakes
and the later development of
neurofibrillary tangles
the purpose of this research project was
to evaluate how the transcript of
microglial cells
varies both between physiological and
pathological conditions
as well as how it changes throughout
aging for my analysis i use the data
from the following study
transcriptomic profiling of microcline
astrocytes throughout aging from
panettal
um distally evaluated the transcription
of microglia and astrocytes from both
wild type and apb ps1 mice
these are double transgenic mice that
exhibit a remarkable elevation of
aminoid beta aggregation
and the data that this study provides
seals valuable information regarding
microglial activation in response to
aging
and amyloid beta pathologies
i performed an rna-seq pipeline
to obtain a the expression levels in raw
it counts as an output so to
obtain a gene expression table with the
expression values for the
uh yeah for the respective genes uh
and then using those raw read count
values we performed an exploratory
principle component analysis
uh to see how the sample is clustered
and so
here we can see that there isn't really
a clear clustering between wild type and
uh 80 samples but here we can see that
when we label
uh samples uh in terms of h we can see
that nine and trouble 12 month old
samples
cluster apart from two four and six
month old samples
uh and based on this observation we
defined uh
two groups uh in terms of h
so with the young samples which are two
four and six month old samples
and the older samples which are nine and
twelve months old samples
uh and yes so here we can see that um
the young and the the young wild type
and the young 80 samples clustered
together
whereas the old wild type and the old
80s samples are clustered apart
in the lower region of the of the
plot then we perform the differential
expression analysis uh
using uh dsec2 we perform these four
a different differential expression
analysis so first we compare the
transcription of young av
uh and old 80 samples so this allows us
to see how the transcript of microglial
cells vary
throughout pathological aging and we did
the same
by comparing young wildlife and old wild
type samples to see how the
transcriptome varied throughout the
normal
non-pathological aging and then we
compared young wild type and young 80
samples
as well as old wild type and old ad
samples
um to see definitely big differences at
age matched groups
and then here we quantified the number
of differentially expressed genes
produced by each differential expression
analysis
and we can see that the greatest number
of differentially expressed genes
uh were produced here between the young
gideon old lady
meaning that there is a greater
phenotypic divergence throughout
pathological aging when compared
to normal nonpathological aging and here
we can see that there was a
rather small number of differentially
expressed genes between the young
samples which is telling us that there
isn't really a penalty there aren't
really
great phenotypic differences between
samples and they support
ch related nature of alzheimer's disease
as phenotypic differences between
healthy and deceased models
arise throughout aging and they are not
present at a young age
here we performed uh here we perform
these volcano bloods
and here we can see that there is a
greater phenotypic divergence
between the old wild type and the old
lady samples and the young kd versus all
led samples
here we can see that there aren't really
there isn't really a great number
of differentially expressed genes
between the young wild different young
kitty samples
and here we can see that although there
is a phenotypic divergence
the number of differentially expressed
genes is not as large in here
as in the young av versus old lady
samples
uh then we perform principal component
analysis using only the
expression values from the
differentially expressed genes we
considered a differential expressed gene
so those
that have a p-value smaller than 0.05
and unlock the full change value
either greater than 1.5 was or smaller
than minus 1.5
and then based on this we perform the
different clustering analyses at the
principal component analysis i'm sorry
and so here we can see that there is
clustering between young av and all
these samples
here we can see that there is clustering
between
all wild type and old 80 samples uh and
here
interestingly we could see that there
was also
here there appeared uh three clusters so
here we see one with two and fourth
month old samples
here we see another one with uh nine and
12 month old samples and here we see one
with
uh six month old samples only which was
uh rather interesting
and here we can see that between the
young type and younger d samples
they are like skewing towards one of the
axes and so there isn't really a clear
clustering or a
difference between the experimental
groups
the results produced by our principal
component analysis were supported by our
hierarchical clustering analysis
so here we can see that there is a
clustering between young 80 and all
these
80 samples so here the two uh
four and six month old samples are
clustering apart from the twelve and
nine months old samples however here we
have an outlier x six month old sample
that we could also see in here uh here
between the young wild type and young 80
samples we see that there isn't
a clear clustering and uh
here uh in fact uh wild type and 80
samples are clustering together
uh so yeah there isn't clear clustering
or a separation between the groups
here between the young wild type and old
wild type samples we could also see
clustering
so here we see the two four and six
month old samples and here we can see
the 9 and 12 month old samples
and here between the old wild type and
old 80 samples here we see 12 and 9
month old samples
and in this region uh yeah i'm sorry
here we can see the wild type samples
and here we can see the 80 samples
um yep and then by selecting the
differentially expressed genes
we perform that incident enrichment
analysis and we could see that there was
an increase in the activity of
neutrophil
of biological processes involving
neutrophils
so here we can see that there was an
increase in neutrophil degranulation
neutrophil activation both in immune
response
and travel mediated immunity throughout
pathological aging so
in all the mice when compared to younger
mice and we can see that there isn't
the same increase throughout uh
physiological non-pathological aging
as we can see an increase in the
activity of neutrophils
um and yeah based on that we could see
that there was an increase in the
activity of inflammatory processes
and other immune mechanisms we could
also see that while type myosin exhibit
increased inflammation
cytokine production or neutrophil
activation uh
and based on the observation of the main
phenotypic difference between wildlife
and adv ps1 mice is that the latter
overproduced amyloid beta
we can infer that the hydrogen activity
of neutrophils
is induced by amyloid beta aggregation
and so uh i researched a little bit
about neutrophils uh
and yeah they're their mechanisms so
neutrophils modulate immune processes
and they play important roles in
pathological inflammation
they are a type of cell known as
granulocyte meaning that they contain
granules inside in their cytoplasm and
so when they become
activated they secrete these granules
which contain
cytotoxic molecules and pro-inflammatory
cytokines that can damage
neurons well in case of the brain but
they can be damaging to cells as they
are cytotoxic
and yeah neutrogens have also been shown
to
orchestrate the activation of other
immune cells such as macrophages
and so it will be really interesting to
evaluate the mechanisms by which
intervals and microglial cells
interact as this could provide us a
further insight into the importance
of the peripheral immune system in the
pathogenesis and progression of
alzheimer's disease
and yeah